it's a true Clash of civilizations it's
a true Clash of culture it's a true
Clash of religion and in this Clash we
cannot let them win and I was set aside
as hysterical I had been um I had been
scarred by my experience uh I had been
um hijacked by rightwing or extreme
rightwing people people couldn't I mean
I had been cast aside so many times and
I keept coming back and I keep telling
you look at this there are 100,000
people three weekends in a row in London
who are
shouting from The River To The Sea
Israel shall be free they shout they're
shouting yelling protesting for a
genocide of the Jews well in 1945 we
said never again this isn't going to
happen ever again but it is happening
the same people with the same ideas are
shouting for the G genocide of the Jews
and the destruction of the state of
Israel in Germany in France in the
Netherlands in Sweden and on American
campuses all right I on my old friend we
have not seen each other for quite some
time but I'm glad to see you I'm glad to
listen to you in Jordan just a moment
ago uh the whole point of Ark is to tell
a better story and I was thinking what's
the best way to start with you well
you're life is the better story yeah I
think is that is that fair to
say well I don't know my life it's been
a long time I mean I've been he I look
at the situation that we're dealing with
now uh with people shouting Hamas and
agitating for genocide and doing it in
the name of religion and um the last 20
years of my life was dedicated to trying
to wake people up in the west to this
Hydra that's many headed it's elusive um
that's there it's a mind virus as ilon
mask calls it but it also is an
Institutional virus and I think if you
say you know is my life a good place to
start you know of my life story that I
document in Infidel yeah and the reason
why I told that story was to talk
to this society that I adopt at Western
Society Western Civilization about what
things look like and feel like and how
people live where I come from using my
life experience and my
observations to tell you what you
shouldn't throw out and throw away so
quickly and as for
Ark um I'm pleased with I arrived this
morning and I saw all of those different
organizations that are fighting for our
civilization in their own ways with the
limited resources that they have with
different audiences all come together
and I hope that that's what AR achieves
bringing us together number one and
number two setting priorities and number
three setting our pride
aside um and number four and that's
probably the most important thing not to
be put in a position where you have to
fight for the same
dollars uh or same Don if if that the
Don issue could be resolved and Fe all
these little organizations didn't have
to worry about you know fund rings in
which is where a lot of time is spent
then I think we could become a movement
for individual freedom and for
everything and it's is good about
westernization do you think that's
shifting a little bit because just in
the last couple weeks we're seeing a lot
of donors dry up and say no more to the
to the colleges no more to Harbor Etc so
maybe they will shift a little bit uh I
hope they do shift a little bit but but
I think we have to work to go to them
and and show them you know you have uh
the Ivy League colleges Harvard Stanford
Hil penit Colombia we have students who
are going there who are there are
cheering for the genocide of
Jews are you kidding me they're cheering
for the genocide of Jews I take it
you're not shocked actually by guess
that anyone would have seen the end of
this I'm always shocked at the banality
at the brazenness of it but I'm not
surprised and I go to a point where I
was really disappointed a few years ago
you've met me I think what I would call
my depressed stage where I thought it's
hopeless uh we're not going to win this
we're not United we're distracted by so
many different in my view trivial
things and we're not fighting for the
big things
and now I hope with this you know
horrific um War that's underway with
what happened on the 7th of October
2023 that we can stand up and say no
we've got to be together against this
thing this thing is evil it isn't that
you know those members of Hamas walked
in and killed Jews because you know
they feel that their land is occupied
they killed babies they beheaded babies
they raped women they gouged people stad
eyes they they humiliated and killed
children in front of their parents and
the other way around they did everything
that is inhuman and they're doing that
to Israel and the Jewish people today
but sooner or later they'll be doing
this to us in fact they did so is that
really what you've always warned about
in a way like that really when when you
came on to the scene whatever it was for
in an American context maybe 20 years
ago or so that to me was what you were
forecasting like pay attention to this
because it could happen it could happen
and I said this it's it's a true Clash
of civilizations it's a true Clash of
culture it's a true Clash of religion
and in this Clash we cannot let them win
and I was set aside as hysterical I had
been um I I had been scarred by my
experience uh I had been um hijacked by
rightwing or extreme rightwing people
people couldn't I mean I had been cast
aside so many times and I keep coming
back and I keep telling you look at this
there are 100,000 people three weekends
in a row in London who are
shouting from The River To The Sea
Israel shall be free there sh there
they're shouting yelling protesting for
a genocide of the Jews well in 1945 we
said never again this isn't going to
happen ever again but it is happening
the same people with the same ideas are
shouting for the genocide of the Jews
and the destruction of the state of
Israel in Germany in France in the
Netherlands in Sweden and on American
cuses so what do you think the proper
response I've asked several people that
have sat in that chair today this same
question what do you think the proper
response is by Western governments I
mean Europe has a very specific version
of this problem because of immigration I
would say us probably has a lesser
version but we don't know how many
people are now in our country what do
you think the proper response is the
proper shortterm response is to stand up
to evil and say and do what President
Biden did and with prime minister sunak
and some other European leaders you know
dragging their feet what they said which
was We Stand squarely behind Israel and
that is when I I say short
term that is the immediate response
where you stand as a collective and you
say we recognize evil and we're going to
stand together against it regardless of
our differences because this thing this
monster is coming for all of us
shortterm long term I think we have to
recognize first of all that this war is
not just a war between Israel and Hamas
it is a war between these different
concepts about Humanity about power
about how we live with one and it's a
civilizational conflict and we have to
invest in winning that civilizational
Conflict by rescuing the minds of our
students by rescuing our institutions by
governing in a way that draws a red line
between what we believe in who we are
versus what they believe in and who they
are it ain't that easy though right I
mean that's the like the real challenge
is well what do you do now when you see
I mean it must have been when when
you've been in London for a few days
when you saw that March I mean yeah
these days we don't have to be
physically in a place to see because
it's all of a social media so I have but
for me to arrive the happen and I happen
to be Jewish right like they're not
thrilled with me yeah absolutely they're
not thrilled they're not thrilled with
you either but no um we're in good
company I suppose yes and the
frustration is also the ignorance there
were people were Maring along with
rainbow Flags queers for Palestine I
know it's supposed you know I should be
laughing about this and think and I saw
you know go to Gaza and let's see how
that goes but that is the seriousness of
our ignorance and our naivity and our
stupidity and our suicidal impulse and
this has been going on I joined this
debate in 2001 and when America was hit
the Twin Towers came down a wing of the
Pentagon was hit plane that was going to
the White House was downed the reaction
was what did we do to deserve this
that's a suicidal
impulse we want asking so some of us I
speak for myself but there were other
individuals born and raised with Islam
who made the choice for Western
Civilization because it's a civilization
that invests in human life we were all
set aside all of us are cast aside so is
the inhering problem or I guess maybe
the asymmetry of this is that we're
taking a radic let's say a radicalized
religion or a version of the religion
and to fight that as a pluralistic
society with all sorts of opinions and
all sorts of people with all sorts of
cultures and foods and everything else
yeah we're we're not equal the the fight
is not equal in a sense because of the
ideology I think it is and it it's right
and it has been right all of these years
to emphasize we're not fighting Muslims
yeah you've always said that You' always
gone ahead and I'm going to say it again
and again I've never had so many Muslims
as friends and I think the the
friendships I have with my Muslim
friends is genuine because they know
precisely what I'm saying it is not a
fight against Muslims it's a fight
against a narrative yes that is rooted
in parts of Islam but that has given
price to entities like the Islamic State
of Iraq and Syria that we sort of half
destroyed we took out the organization
but the idea is still there it's an
entity called Hamas it is the Islamic
Republic of Iran it is all of these men
mostly men organized in mosques and in
Islamic schools and in other
infrastructure that are doing you know
they're doing their best they're
investing every waking
hour in an advancing this vision of
humanity and it is a vision that is
rooted in death they say they love death
more than life that's what we are
fighting and that's tough to to fight
that is not to conflct it with Muslims
the biggest victims are Muslims the
biggest victims of Hamas are the
Palestinian people in Gaza the women and
children who are being bombed yet again
because they start this over and over
again they are the victim so we
shouldn't be wasting time amongst
ourselves saying oh so you want a
genocide for Palestinians no I don't
want a genocide for Palestinians nobody
does no I want life for Palestinians I
want them to feel safe and be safe and
Lead prosperous lives and the way to do
that is for us as we are more powerful
to fight Hamas we fight Hamas for our
own sake but we also fight Hamas for
their own sake in retros back now you
mentioned you know when you first
started getting out the scene here the
way people would talk about you and you
know we're far right and all the Nonet
yeah in some respects isn't doesn't this
moment seem like it was
inevitable in a certain regard meaning
that all of the people who were warning
about this were so castigated were so
pushed out of the mainstream that there
was no defense against this in in in the
said the pushing out of the people who
come and give you
uh the harsh the harsh reand because
that's what it is yeah um that is it's a
phenomenon I've been trying to
understand it I don't know why I mean
forget about me um Professor s h 1989 we
were at a crossroad and so many
different people within the
international relations scholarship were
trying to figure out what is the world
going to look like and the one man
Professor Huntington who talks about
civilization and culture that they're
going to clash they're going to compete
that nonwestern
um civilizations like China like Russia
like Islam they would find somehow
downplay their own differences and gang
up on Western Civilization all of that
is unfolding now you look back in that
time and you think how have we treated
him and his work he passed away sadly
but how have we treated him how have
treated all of those other people who
told us the truth how do we even treat
I'm now reading journalistic reports of
what happened on the
7eventh and the 43 minutes of
video and some of the journalism is a
guy I admire him so much I think he's
amazing he's poting on it gam wood and
he's describing that scene where a man
kills children babies and he calls on
WhatsApp using one of the victim's
phones calls his father and mother to
say you should be proud of me look I
killed 10 Jews and this is what I did to
them and I is gwood has written this in
the Atlantic and I what fascinated me
about it is gwood is trying to guess the
reaction of the
parents right it doesn't need to be
guessed I don't think so he wouldn't
have called his parents this is a kid
who is saying I think you will be proud
of me and their reaction was an
expression that they are proud
of the banality of evil remember Hanah
it can be sometimes that banal but we
have this impulse in western
civilization today for those of us who
are going through all of this in the
last 20 years what I have seen is this
stubbornness this bloody mindedness to
deny and live in
deny all right I will have time for one
more so I want to ask you say on a more
personal side of all this which is after
everything you've been through and I'm
sure everyone watching this n is your
story and they can watch our before they
should read your book and they should
watch our original interviews and
everything I I do sense a little bit of
a renewed purpose maybe from last time I
saw you because we saw each other a
couple years ago and you were as you
said you were kind
of well I don't want to put words about
but you were sort of depressed about
everything things are seemingly worse at
the moment but I sense you personally
maybe you're a little more uh well back
in the fight I don't know how to
describe it exactly yeah I felt
depressed I felt felt like a failure not
on a personal level but a failure of it
this it was worth nothing I mean I had
been
um threatened um had to live in safe
houses have to live with
security uh obviously I sometimes ask
myself the question what am I doing all
of this W when the people who inherited
are just ready to throw it away and and
that depresses me
and now I
feel I'm doing it for my children I'm
doing it for my husband I'm doing it for
I have I I feel a sense of purpose and I
live in the hope that we will wake up
and I feel like we are waking up look at
ARK the fact that we brought all of
these different organizations together
who are all
somewhat shouting in the woods all along
today we're sitting together and trying
to contemplate you know who are we
exactly what is it we are fighting for
what kind of future do we want how do we
identify the enemy what are the tools
that we have and the resources how can
we Salvage the institutions that we have
and that gives me hope that puts me back
in the mood of yeah I'm not alone we are
doing this thing together but it takes
it always takes an atrocity to get us to
talk about these things we forget so
easily and we forget so fast Ian I know
you don't like extra credit but I think
Jordan's a prophet and I think you're an
angel so there you go well David thank
you and thank you for what you do and
thank you for all of this time that you
dedicated to fighting the good fight in
your way it's all we can do yeah if
you're looking for more enlightening
conversations about international issues
check out our International playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics watch our full
episode playl is all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell